le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
écologie éco-citoyens développement
durable sont des expressions qui font
partie pleinement de notre actualité en
général la Réunion sert d'exemple car
elle possède beaucoup de ressources en
énergie naturelle
notre département pourrait même devenir
autosuffisant en énergie dans un futur
proche pour atteindre cet objectif nous
devons respecter notre environnement
mais notre comportement n'est pas
toujours adapté il y a beaucoup de
points sur lesquels nous devons
améliorer notre attitude éco-citoyenne
comme la gestion de nos déchets
l'utilisation de l'eau de l'électricité
mais aussi notre façon de conduire car
notre conduite a un impact direct sur
notre environnement et notre
portefeuille alors qui peut nous
apprendre les bons gestes pour avoir une
écho conduite on en parle maintenant
dans lien social
pour sensibiliser une partie de ces
agents le Conseil général a mis en place
une formation à l'éco-conduite cette
formation a pour but d'informer les
usagers sur leur façon de conduire mais
également de proposer des solutions en
donnant des astuces et des méthodes pour
conduire avec le moins d'impact possible
sur notre environnement le département a
donc proposé cette formation aux agents
et chauffeurs qui travaillent au sein
même du conseil général yvralin a
bénéficié de cette formation et a pu
revoir sa façon d'utiliser son véhicule
beaucoup d'entre nous prend le fait de
conduire comme un acquis et oublie que
cela reste un privilège
conduire devient une habitude la routine
s'installe à la longue machinalement on
prend le volant on quitte chez soi on va
vers les vers le son lieu de travail on
a souvent la tête dans les avec le
travail et pas forcément avec la
circulation les usagers donc on prend
des habitudes qui à mon sens est
peut-être négatif pour le pour le
chauffeur voilà donc machine finalement
on enclenche les vitesses on le
programme on freine on suit le flux de
véhicule et en plus on se dit souvent si
on a des remarques j'ai plus de 30 ans
de permis est-ce que vous voulez vous
que je dise de plus je sais conduire il
est vrai aussi que cette formation m'a
beaucoup aidé c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à prendre de mauvaises
habitudes comme je le disais donc de la
routine mais par contre ça m'a aidé à
une conduite sûre ça m'a aidé à une
conduite économique et responsable
vis-à-vis des usagers et de
l'environnement
ça m'a aidé à mettre en pratique des
techniques simples de conduite tout
simplement conduire mon véhicule à sa
capacité de fonctionnement optimale de
manière à économiser du carburant ce qui
n'est pas négligeable aujourd'hui avec
le coût de le prix de de l'essence
cette formation m'a appris aussi donc la
pratique de l'éco-conduite qui passe par
5 règles fondamentales
première règle changer les rapports à
bas régime moteur deuxième règle
maintenir une vitesse stable
troisième règle il utilisait un régime
moteur le plus bas possible quatrième
règle anticiper le ralentissement du
trafic cinquième règle entretenir son
véhicule
grâce à cette formation
ivrin fait maintenant bien plus
attention à sa manière de conduire car
il est conscient de son impact sur
l'environnement il gère son véhicule
différemment depuis cette formation le
Conseil général a constaté de gros
changements sur les consommations de
carburant c'est une preuve qu'avoir une
conduite écologique c'est avoir une
conduite économique en amont depuis deux
ans nous avons mis en place une
formation à l'endroit de nos agents qui
sont chauffeurs et donc il s'agit pour
nous de faire le lien entre la conduite
sécurité à responsable et la conduite
économique cette formation a permis a
permis véritablement et bien de
responsabilité
de responsabiliser pardon les agents qui
en tout cas empruntent le un véhicule
donc au final se comportement aura des
effets sur
la baisse de la consommation à
qui dit baisse de consommation forcément
c'est c'est moins de pollution et le but
c'est bien entendu de faire des
économies d'être responsable et de faire
des économies de temps plus que les
études nous ont prouvées qui a eu
pendant ces deux ans de formation étalée
et bien des résultats très probants à
hauteur de 20 à 25%
. la Réunion toute entière est concernée
par le développement durable
l'implication et l'investissement du
conseil général dans ce domaine ont été
reconnus au niveau national la
collectivité représentée par la
présidente nasimadin a ainsi reçu la
récompense les Rubans du développement
durable pour la période 2012 2014
les coconduite n'est qu'un des aspects
de cette application quotidienne que
nous devons tous mettre en pratique pour
léguer à nos enfants la plus belle des
réunions possible
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais